les séries la bc du poste est parti
contre qui denis brogniart at il fait
part de son dégoût
allez j'ai posé la question à valérie
benaïm contrôle trop long teaser si vous
payez contre les oiseaux de l'île qui
font leurs besoins sur sa cabane contre
les candidats manipulateur contre ceux
qui menacent les aventuriers ou contre
les téléspectateurs qui mangent des
pizzas devant l'émission il aime pas
phare de nine ce qui m'énerve c'est
d'aventuriers et bien contre ceux qui
menacent et dentu rien on va voir si
valérie bénaïm la meilleure élève de la
classe encore donné une bonne réponse
regardez alors je voudrais vous dire mon
dégoût ma consternation
ma colère aussi devant les messages
haineux scandaleux reçu par certains
aventuriers je les ai cité
régis inès charlotte alexandra et bien
sûr auparavant hamad
mais alors dans quel monde vit-on
comment peut-on menacé de mort insultes
et promettre le pire à des aventuriers
de koh lanta
ces messages sont l'oeuvre d'une infime
minorité des grilles de jaloux des gens
qui méritent a minima le mépris et le
pire c'est que tous ou presque sévices
sous couvert d'anonymat
son courage de leurs propos en se
cachant derrière un pseudo guidon et
j'adore denis brogniart même complice
vénère on dirait qu'il va donner une
épreuve de koh lanta
il s'agit tout ça dans l'anonymat non
mais alors le braille de koh lanta ce
vendredi a beaucoup fait réagir sur les
réseaux à tel point que certains
candidats ont reçu des menaces de mort
et des insultes
c'est notamment le cas de régis et inès
depuis il ya eu énormément de réactions
la société de production donc un boulet
et vu denis brogniart en passant par
d'anciens candidats de jeu on milite
plus de tout ça pour quoi ils ont été
menacés regarde
vendredi soir dernier sam était éliminée
de koh lanta l'île des héros une
décision qui est loin d'avoir fait
l'unanimité sur les réseaux et pour une
fois les échanges entre les internautes
ont un peu dépassé la sempiternelle
guerre des clans propre programme
certains d'entre eux très en colère
après cette élimination ont même franchi
allègrement la ligne jaune en proférant
des menaces de mort à l'encontre des
autres aventuriers sur instagram inez
tim de ces attaques a décidé d'exprimer
sa tristesse visiblement très émue elle
déclare qu ce même chose pour régis qui
avait reçu des messages menaçants
directement sa famille j'espère que des
enfants vont mourir je vais te retrouver
tu étais fille de violentes attaques qui
ont fait réagir denis brogniart lors
d'un live instagram l'animateur du jeu a
déclaré je voudrais vous dire mon dégoût
ma consternation
ma colère aussi devant les messages
haineux scandaleux reçu par certains
aventuriers je les ai cité régis inès
charlotte alexandra et bien sûr
auparavant hamad
mais dans quel monde vit-on comment
peut-on menacé de mort insultes et
promettre le pire à des aventuriers de
koh lanta
très agacé il a poursuivi ses messages
sont l'oeuvre d'une infime minorité des
grilles de jaloux des gens qui méritent
a minima le mépris une colère qui est
aussi celle de la société alp qui
produit le jeu face à ces menaces
elle a décidé de saisir le procureur de
la république de paris des propos et
menaces dont ont été victimes plusieurs
concurrents en attendant et pour calmer
le jeu sam a lui aussi accepté de
prendre la parole sur les réseaux pour
demander aux internautes de garder leur
calme
on m'a fait part de toute la violence
tous les messages très violent et la
haine qui a été déversé à mes camarades
aventure une élimination qui prend des
proportions démesurées
moi je le kiffe ce sable sais pas pour
vous mais j'adore ça
j'avais vu la pokal ma lancée il est
tellement aimé d'ailleurs que c'est ça
que voilà car engendré voilà ces menaces
de mort est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui
sont tellement dans le programme
voilà qu'ils y voient là ils en veulent
énormément aux autres candidats je pense
que tout ça va se tasser un mine de rien
voilà faux pas je pense pas que ça se
soit voilà c'est ce soir extrêmement
c'est grave de faire ça mais je pense
que ça va se passer
voilà c'est damien mercereau moi qui m'a
mis au courant de télé mag qui m'a parlé
ça qui est sur l'enquêté il nous donnera
d'autres infos prochainement oui jean
michel vrai on rigole quand vous
terminez chaque jour l'émission par la
télé c'est que date c'est vrai cette
phrase là pour tout son sens la télé
c'est dans notre jeu c'est du
divertissement les jours ils deviennent
tout à coup tout ça c'est de la télé ça
s'est arrêté aujourd'hui arrêter tu as
raison mon chéri je suis d'accord oui
mathieu bah oui mais surtout ce que
devrait de comprendre denis brogniart
c'est que à l'époque on recevait des
sacs entiers les animateurs de courrier
alors il y avait des résultats négatifs
mais eiter du fait des thèmes qui
prennent un stylo qu'il écrit kim est
attaché un petit niamien c'était un
effort aujourd'hui à plus d'efforts à
faire non ligne est insulté quelqu'un
mais je pense qu'il ya pas plus de
hauteur de jean débile et insultant
aujourd'hui qu'il ya vingt ans c'est
juste que là on leur donne la parole en
un clic
également je suis assez d'accord c'est
bien ce qu'il dit matthieu delormeau
valérie venez vous lire réagir non non
je voulais simplement dire que rien ne
justifie un tel flot de violences et des
appels au meurtre vous appelle au viol
onze enfants sans leurs compagnes ou
leur compagnon
ça y est absolument inadmissible et
effectivement quand vous disiez comme
vous dites tous les soins et les cadets
c'est que la télé est vraiment là il va
falloir coraux des sentiers et
l'enfermer pour dire à arrêter même si
vous m'aimez mais tout ça n'est qu'un
jeu on redescend d'un cran quoi oui rené
malleville rené oui moi piqué il ya
longtemps que les celeron mixte du net
que j'appelle iso même pseudo et un
clavier c'est héroïque mais
malheureusement il n'ya pas que les
terroristes de la télé je te prendrais a
simplement du football le milieu que je
connais très bien bien sûr supporters et
le départ des équipes présumées pas cité
il céder ccnm d'alain ce que je lis de
sur les réseaux sociaux
ce n'est pas possible c'est publie ses
râles et les trois ça je l'aimais que tu
rencontres à perte des cortèges de
salina antiraciste comment bien sûr et
une fois qu'ils sont devant leurs caves
et les rôles de l'eau était sévère c'est
une merde a recensé croyable j'essaie
rhône et bein sûr et son fameux no 10
mais ce n'est que du football belling
cela dit ce n'est que de la télé
manning sur wii s'offre un autre cas
sans nom mais en ce moment en ce moment
quand même les gens passent trois à
quatre fois plus de temps sur leur écran
devant a effectivement les réseaux
sociaux donc il ya une espèce
d'exacerbation de la no6 alors quoi
qu'on voit beaucoup de choses très drôle
sur instagram extra mais on voit aussi
ça et on assiste à des déferlements
comme ça comme dit rené effectivement de
merde et la télé ça a toujours existé
mais en ce moment j'apprends ken
exacerbation comme alsace qui vient non
mais les gens et je les outils c'est
vrai j'ai tout gérer c'est vrai que
tourneur violence et tous vos tracas de
la violence et alors on va sans doute y
avait du marché et franck ribéry dans un
instant bien entendu vous crevez de quel
côté je suis un pas besoin de vous le
dire mais on le prendra
on va passer à la troisième question d'
enquête exclusive avec moi un nudiste se
cache-t-il le sexe avec une chaussette
avec une avec un rouleau de sopalin avec
une photo de valérie bénaïm ou avec un
bonnet de noël à la légère
une chose est ce que je dois travailler
une chaussette
merci monsieur le maire toujours 100% de
mauvaises réponses
voilà je ne regardais adeptes du nudisme
ils ont amené avec eux des dizaines
d'accessoires car ici il ya une règle à
respecter et c'est pour cela que les
nudistes se font peindre le corps il est
interdit de sortir complètement nue dans
la rue il faut se couvrir les parties
génitales
c'est la loi alors et trois amis doivent
ruser
vous n'avez qu'à mettre seulement une
goutte de peinture sur le téton et ses
bons juges des peintures sur la tête au
hockey mais par contre si vous avez les
tétons découvert là c'est pas bon ça n'a
pas de sens en cas d'infraction l'amendé
peut atteindre 900 euros alors les trois
amis se creuse la tête pour être le plus
d'élus des possibles afin de se faire
remarquer
tout en respectant la loi et ça c'est un
coin 88 enquêtes ça fait rêver ça un run
et je sais que tu adores ce genre de
d'extraits je pense que ça d'ailleurs
regardez les ils ouvrent les yeux des
messieurs puisque j'ai bien vu les
séries 4 4 ont pu voir hier sur bfm tv
montbazens ils ont une régie pire que
celle de ses vies d'ailleurs d embrasser
fondé et des prouesses un serveur et
toutes les équipes
ils sont les premiers à avoir re mis
côte à côte des journalistes les
journalistes ont donné une information
sans prononcer les mots attentats
coronavirus malouda ils ont une coupure
de faisceaux de 20 minutes
je pense que c'est la réponse ce numéro
2 donc ils sont les premiers à avoir re
mis côte à côte les journalistes urbain
oui eh bien regardez où d'affilée avant
et le après bravo benji qui travaillent
bien bravo motion a bien sûr c'est quand
tu y penses que tu es nul c'est tout
bien sûr bravo décisions fortes à
présent l'état a annoncé hier qu'elle
réquisitionnait les stocks et la
production de masques de protection car
il ya flambée des prix et surtout
l'exécutif veut contrôler la
distribution des répétitions que c'est
mal et inexorablement donc le corona
virus continue de progresser avec des
situations qui se tendent chaque jour un
peu plus dans les hôpitaux et c'est la
preuve supplémentaire il faut vraiment
vraiment rester à la maison
avant d'évoquer les derniers arbitrages
avant la présentation demain à 15 heures
donc du plan de déconfinement notre
enquête sur les masques point clé
évidemment de ce plan et plus
précisément le trafic de masques alors
qu'adeline que les pharmacies sont
autorisés 2000 ce week-end à vente des
masques dits grand public
alors je vous pose la question ça vous
choque qu'ils ont remis les deux
présentateurs côte à côte ou bien pas du
tout est ce que vous trouvez ça normal
ou ou non benjamin ben c'est un peu la
question qu'on se pose non pour le
retour à l'arrêt le on sait je me suis
je me trompe pas est ce qu'on doit
effectivement jamais pamart jour je vous
parle de dès maintenant j ai qui ont dit
que c'était pas normal donc c'est pour
ça que vous pouvez pas normal c'est pas
normal
effectivement c'est par là ils sont loin
sont moins longs d'accord ils sont ils
sont à côté je suis désolé série alors
il qu'ils soient à mettre un médecin
mais demain c'est pas un bon exemple on
doit effectivement montré l'exemple pour
la télévision
c'est déjà très bien jean michel bats je
trouve que le système qui est navrant
pour le continent on avait l'impression
que j'étais là que des doses n'étaient
pas là côtés d'autres c'était très bien
pourquoi avoir pris de l'avancé comme ça
franchement c'est pas un bon exemple
non c'est pas bien r1 rené ouais moi
surtout aider les chaînes d'information
le matin où ils sonnent comme c'est
autour de la table mais bon merci rené
kuhn moi je m'attendais environné
alors les cherry a là c'est un sujet que
je voulais aborder
pourquoi la mère de neymar est le
footballeur neymar at-elle largué son
copain parce qu'il était déjà marié
parce qu'il sortait avec des garçons
parce qu'il lui a volé de l'argent ou
parce que comme son fils au foot
il simule et sophie cottes sophie marche
la réponse b parce qu'ils sortent avec
des garçons
eh bien regardez on vous raconte cette
histoire et après j'attends vos
réactions je pense que mathieu va se
régaler parce que ça avait été le plus
virulent sur cet axe et y regarde il ya
quelques semaines on vous parlait de la
maman de neymar qui pendant que son fils
rapporte des millions en jouant balle on
s'occupe comme elle peut et le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle ne semble
pas s'ennuyer le 11 avril dernier nadine
goncalves âgé de 52 ans posté sur son
compte instagram des photos de son petit
ami thiago ramos un jeune mannequin de
22 ans une relation que semblait
supporter neymar commentant à plusieurs
reprises les publications de sa maman et
du jeune homme sauf que voilà en
quelques jours la belle histoire semble
avoir tourné au vinaigre
selon le journal britannique the sun les
deux amoureux se seraient même séparés
d'après le magazine durant le
confinement le jeune homme serait
retourné chez sa mère mais the sun ne
s'arrête pas là toujours selon des
sources proches du dossier ce n'est pas
pour une autre femme que tiago ramos
aurait quitté la maman de neymar mais
pour d'autres hommes
en effet le jeune homme aurait eu une
relation avec le cuisinier privé de
neymar junior quelques semaines avant de
se mettre en couple avec sa maman et
également avec le comédien brésilien de
28 ans carlinhos maya face à ces
révélations c'est la famille de neymar
très religieuse qui aurait mis la
pression à nadine pour qu'elle arrête
cette relation une pression à laquelle
elle semble avoir cédé mathieu balle a
alors mathieu tu m'as dit que tu n'y
croyait pas à cette histoire
mathieu casting mais écoutez c'est
horrible mais malheureusement on est
toujours à prêter par la réalité
effectivement ce qu'ils avaient vu une
belle histoire là dedans se trompaient n
était pas possible
c'est l'histoire d'un jeune garçon 28
ans homosexuel voilà le seul à très bien
et qui effectivement a fait du buzz
on a parlé de lui il a gagné des
followers à mon avis comme lui a fait
les yeux doux
il a peut-être gagné une montre en or et
quelques cadeaux delà de la maman neymar
voilà j'avais dit elle c'était une
escorte
on en a la preuve aujourd'hui c'était
une escorte qui s'est marré une semaine
avec une personne un petit peu plus
âgées cas de l'argent voilà dans la vie
faut se méfier de doux alors que sophie
cost moi j'adore les maraîchers sein
c'est un super mec mais comme à
m'envoyer est moi je vais vous dire un
truc sa maman elle s'est fait plaisir et
s'est faite en mairie et ben elle fait
ce qu'elle veut maintenant à moi je
quitte un démarrage qui fait sa maman
voilà je veux dire oui et sophie non
mais c'est vrai que neymar il avait été
vraiment exemplaire sur cette histoire
avec sa maman d'un grand dans l'histoire
d'amour etc et on avait vraiment envie
pour une fois mathieu de croire à une
romance véritable est effectivement pas
le type s'avère une fraude
donc tu avais raison à free wheels
valérien troubles ayant un truc non
après moi je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord avec ben et naïve mais quand
arrive si le fruitier tu peux manger des
bananes et d'abricot comme je suis
désolé non mais c'est vrai voilà bah oui
l'iphone dit bah oui et qui ne principal
c'est qu'il s'agissait de deux personnes
majeures consentant ce qu'ils sont fait
du bien qui sont fait plaisir d'être
chacun pour des raisons différentes
personnalités orthez web qui s'apprêtait
néanmoins que la paume en regard avec
engageant ciel était en miettes alors
écrit un livre comme l'a fait loi là
parce qu'elle a vécu
oui jean michel oui chez eux je faisais
un peu naïf et moi quand je gagne deux
millions d'euros par mois
et ben si ma mère serait un petit milo
de bantanges même petit billet de 100
pour des pays respectifs pour savoir si
le mec a des bonnes des bonnes
intentions auprès de ma mère
ah oui c'est cependant le minimum ah oui
pardon je veux dire un mot oui il
mathieu oui non d'abord excuse-moi année
aux jeunes bien neymar enfin que tient
dans le food allées du nez tant d'amour
au bout d'une semaine
d'abord ceux qui s'effondrent affecta
mourrai avec vous rêvez pas ce que c'est
qu'un coup de foudre fait parce que
c'est quand viendrait bien sûr shawish
denim n'en veut toujours trouver du
positif dans tout non valérie sont pas
fait plaisir c'est un mec
pardon c'est un mec mollet vu dans les
bars boîtes de nuit c'est un homosexuel
ken les beaux mecs de l'examen on peut
dire à castaldi si peu parlé à sa
famille mais dehors
merci est ce que le gars j'entends
j'entends y en a plus dans le frigo
non mais on reverra jamais il fout de
notre gueule non mais alors ils veulent
enlever l'europe qui règle ses arrières
2/3 environ après bernard après merci
oui benjamin et mathieu il est normal
exceptionnellement bas paul valéry on
vient de voir le sujet l'arc illégaux
les de la mort histoire avec des mecs
ses olé schell 28 ans et il est
homosexuel et u13 qui s'est fait que la
mère une semaine avec une vague de 58
ans valérie attend d'eux un homme de 52
ans est pas si vous ne trouvez pas
d'excusés rien à part aleri bon et rené
se voir les corps découverts j'ai jamais
trop cool
aya bassiste il a bavé sur ses gardes
non c'est pas une cougar gens c'est pas
une cougar les couilles armero nec rené
tu plaisantes ans passait pas et qu'il
faut afficher avec un nom origin trouve
que cette expression immonde d'amener
les femmes les cougars c'est une femme
jalouse erronée non mais va passer rhône
et non il est très premier degré rené
non là on a affaire effectivement comme
dit mathieu à une fraude à une escorte
c'est plutôt lui il faut afficher pas
cette femme que les gens croient quoique
live mal que c'est le gran d'amour qui
va nous parler par un visage si jamais
tu n'hésites pas les dames pas voir été
jean michel on critique beaucoup les
réseaux sociaux mais dans ce cas précis
qu'on va faire a vite fait un tour sur
son instagram sur facebook les stars où
habite à peu le type de personnage
possède pas besoin de faire beaucoup
plus pour qu'ils auraient pu se méfier
un peu plus que cinq mois